MedlinePlus is the National Library of Medicine's consumer
health resource designed specifically for caregivers,
patients, and family members.
The scenario you are about to view is just one of the many
ways MedlinePlus can be used.
Michelle's mother, Vivian, was diagnosed this year with
Alzheimer's disease.
Even though Michelle had read and heard about Alzheimer's
disease, she wanted to learn more about the disease
and possible treatments.
As her mother's primary caregiver,
Michelle also understands the importance of maintaining
her own health.
A librarian friend suggested that Michelle go online to the
National Library of Medicine's website, medlineplus.gov.
These pages are a great place to start when looking for quality
health information you can trust.
The MedlinePlus homepage provides an outline of all the
information the website has to offer.
Displayed at the top of the screen are new and
featured health topics.
Michelle clicked on the ESPANOL button and was pleased to find
the site was also available in Spanish.
She wanted to return to the English version of the site,
so she clicked on the ENGLISH button.
A little further down on the homepage,
there are three tabs that link to the Health Topics,
Drugs and Supplements and Videos and Cool Tools sections.
The tabs are located on every MedlinePlus page.
Michelle can also search each of these categories by using the
Search box at the top of each page.
The Health Topics section provides information on
disorders and conditions, diagnosis and therapy,
health and wellness, and population groups.
The Drugs and Supplements section offers information on
prescription drugs, over-the-counter medicines,
dietary supplements, and herbal remedies.
The Videos and Cool Tools section provides videos and
interactive tutorials about medical conditions, treatments,
and procedures as well as anatomy and surgery videos.
The Medical Dictionary is very useful in helping Michelle
understand medical terms.
Michelle learns something new every time she visits the
MedlinePlus website.
Helpful new information on the homepage banner always
catches her attention.
At the bottom of the page, Michelle discovered links to
Directories for locating libraries, health professionals,
and services; Organizations with health information;
and a Medical Encyclopedia with illustrated articles about
diseases, tests, and symptoms.
Health News is a convenient way for Michelle to read press
announcements from major health organizations.
Michelle also noted that she could register to receive email
updates when new information is available on Alzheimer's disease
and other health topics of interest to her.
Michelle was also very excited to see that a Mobile version of
MedlinePlus was available to use on her smartphone.
This concludes the MedlinePlus homepage scenario.
Whether you are a caregiver, patient, or family member,
we hope that you have found this information useful.
For additional information, please visit MedlinePlus.gov.